ces images vont elles bientôt appartenir
au passé avec 80 mille véhicules qui
l'empruntent tous les jours la nationale
10 est un enjeux structurants depuis une
vingtaine d'années pour la ville de
trappes ce mercredi 14 décembre les
collectivités ont enfin signé le
protocole d'accord pour l'enfouissement
partiel de lax sur près de 800 mètres
un projet de 95 millions d'euros dont 28
à la charge de la région ile de france
cette saignée urbaine au milieu de
trappes les trappistes ne la méritais
pas j'ai toujours pensé qu'il fallait
réparer cette cicatrice qu'il fallait
futur et ce territoire et permettre à la
ville de trappes de redevenir une ville
j'allais dire où il fait bon vivre et où
les deux morceaux de la ville sont
recoller les travaux de l'enfouissement
partiel de la nationale 10 devrait
débuter en 2018 la couverture de l'axé
la modification de deux carrefours
permettront de redessiner en profondeur
la commune on alla de l'espace pour
faire du pour faire du paysage pour
faire des choses qu'ils soient de vrais
en entrée de ville est donc d'accord on
rentre dans trappe rendant dans une
ville qui a eu qu à une allure qui a un
paysage c'est à mes yeux très important
si le calendrier des travaux est tenue à
l'aménagement total de la nationale 10
sera bouclée en 2021 soit 23 ans après
les premières études consacrées aux
projets